welcome back sisters I'm your witchy guy
Jessica Clemens giving you my Hocus
Pocus 2 breakdown you know I love all
things Halloween so I promise to not let
you down especially in my witch dress I
have a lot of these and let me tell you
I cried at this movie I loved it I
cannot wait to share with you all the
callbacks of the first movie that I saw
because there's a ton so let's get
started and also just so you guys know
I'm gonna be spoiling this movie so if
you haven't seen it go ahead and go
watch it right now and then come back to
this breakdown where I show you all
these things because it's a lot
[Music]
Disney's giving us the scary Sinister
version of Cinderella's castle it's
Halloween time y'all the moon
illuminates the gray skies and the music
goes from Whimsy to dimly
the movie opens giving a similar
interest to the first movie and how
winifred's outline can be seen flying
over the Everglades instead of winner
Fred we get this slightly colorful Raven
which we'll see more later we're also
starting in Salem 1653 and with the
young young and very mean Winifred
Sanderson played by Taylor Henderson
it's her birthday she just turned 16 and
her sister's Sarah Mary are celebrating
Sarah Mary are played by Juju Journey
Brenner and Nina kitchen we learn here
that their father died leaving the three
girls to fend for themselves reason
number one why the end of the movie
should tug at your heartstrings and also
I think little Mary and Sarah might have
been amongst the first people to create
Jello more so just gelatin because as we
know it was made from boiled bones
connective tissues and other animal
products that's the part of the witch me
I can't take Mary brings up the Turner
boys who might have locked Winnie in the
hay Barrack again she's probably
referring to the Captain John Turner and
his family who own the Turner Ingersoll
Mansion AKA The House of the Seven
Gables the Reverend is also played by
Tony Hale and we also know he plays the
mayor later on and bless the Stars we
see are young Billy butcherson now
surely you remember Billy is a zombie
that came back to life in the first
movie allegedly winifred's lover who she
caught messing around with Sarah so when
he poisoned him so is his mouth with a
dull needle so even in death he couldn't
tell her secrets we see their calming
Circle which is another callback to the
first movie rabid bats Black Death mummy
scorpion pie we later hear the siren
song that Sarah normally sings Come
Little Children and the coolest witch
transforms to the Raven we saw earlier
he's played by Hannah waddingham if you
know Ted lasso that's where she's from
She's credited as the witch mother
snatching Sarah right up it doesn't
affect when you're married though which
is probably the reason why Sarah loves
that song so much our first appearance
from book it's been too long book holds
all the Spells and is the key to all
witchcraft in the first movie I don't
think we ever got such an up close and
personal view of the inside of the book
but it's officially declared the manual
of Witchcraft and Alchemy with all loads
of different spells Mary mentions doing
in the cat spell on John Pritchett
another call back to the spell that
we've done on Thackery Binks in the
first movie Zachary Binks if you don't
have a black cat named Factory Binks
you're doing it wrong Thackery we're in
Salem during present day now skeleton
stand by Lovecraft plays while Becca
bikes by little costume children and a
Puritan villager walks right past
perfect it must be Halloween time it's
nice to add that the original movie shot
in Salem Massachusetts but this one did
not once they switched directors they
decided to shoot in Rhode Island but
they keep the Salem Essence and
Providence style buildings there so it
kind of feels the same we also see the
Raven above could be the eyes from the
witch mother at the beginning the girls
Cassie played by Lila Buckingham backup
played by Whitney Peak and Izzy played
by Melissa Escobedo attend Samuel
skeleton High School Samuel skeleton was
the first pastor of the Church of Salem
go Puritans that's that's their mascot
and Becca just turned 16 the year which
is get their powers
I don't have him and then that's Matt
The Village Idiot as the Sanderson
sisters would say played by Freud
Gutierrez the first class science
reactions explorations of elements
molecules and the change in the universe
book I mean oh what better textbook for
a young witch I'd say and her Good Luck
Stone is turquoise so to bring luck
peace and protection if you haven't
noticed Cassie Becca and Izzy each have
the same necklace as a circle with
different phases of the moon around them
like a little charm Becca has an
additional necklace of the Sun and Izzy
has one of the Moon I love when Becca
starts to recite vegan foods just to
scare Max the tempeh chorizo
garbanzo say that she says Satan it
sounds like Satan so I understand where
Cassie's coming from I like this more
than Max giving Allison his phone number
in the middle of class like in the first
movie because what was that we see the
sign for the 27th annual Salem scare
fest three centuries of History a
weekend of fun the man most excited for
this is Tony Hale who plays the Mayor
Jeffrey chask also Cassie's father they
note how her family dates all the way
back to Witch Trials which is probably
why he loves Halloween so much I love
the marriages being a parent that's
supportive of his daughter even playing
around with which stuff like he's very
encouraging he thinks it's really cute
if the movie went away that was like no
witch things even as a joke I wouldn't
have liked it as much so I like how the
mayor's character is the Sanderson
sisters house is now settled in a suburb
and renamed Old Salem magic shop potions
and Gifts there's a trolley called
Gilbert the Great Ghost trolley right
outside the owner an Entertainer is
Gilbert played by Sam Richardson which
whenever I see this man all I can think
about is the baby sketch firm I think
you should leave the new Sanderson house
is built to the brim with memorabilia
it's basically a gift shop we see the
Thurston poster in the back the Houdini
poster as well later the imitation black
flame candles that you can buy from the
first movie and Magic Salt we see book a
black cat not Thackery being so this is
cobweb we also see Salem Apothecary
which could be a callback to earlier
where the Sanderson sisters father's
profession Angelica leaves which are
known for General protection especially
against evil spirits and hex break-ins
you know a lot of spooky stuff you know
a lot of spooky magic shops or occult
shops usually have just like a ton of
stuff in them and a lot of different
witchy things so I think the art
Department was just trying to give that
lure off we get the call back to Emily
binks's death the reason the Sanderson
sisters were hanging in the first place
I love that instead of telling us the
rules about the Sanderson sisters coming
back we actually just get a Heckler like
just a Heckler in a crowd that's
confirming everything for Gilbert like
that blackfame candle can only bring
them back for one night dude stop asking
questions and stop being a the historic
district once home to the Sanderson
sisters in the 1600s is now a national
landmark with the Forbidden Forest
nearby that Becca felt drawn to Once
Izzy places the photo of the three girls
down Becca lights the black flame candle
it won't go out we hear Sarah's song
that she sings in the first movie that
lures children you remember the garden
of magic song and the first movie when
the Sanderson sisters arrived the wind
howled indoors the ground shook light
bulbs burst and the green light beckoned
underneath the floorboards here the
ground still shakes but a red light
crack extends in the forest but I love
that for a brief moment they turn off
the moon that's so insane the Sanderson
sisters are back they're immediately
singing and I love this Bette Midler
said let me sing this is the witches are
back which is to the a tune of Elton
John's the [ __ ] is back and let me tell
you I'm so into this song I love the
chorus they're exactly how I'd imagine
them older after being gone for almost
30 years just super silly Mary recounts
the last time they were with book
calling back to the first movie when
they were in the cottage and the boys
were in the cages they're talking about
the bullies Ernie AKA ice and Jay they
died by Sunrise oh okay when I say they
died by Sunrise I mean
they take them to Walgreens for
age-defying products which is funny
because I feel like they should have
just done that in the first movie and it
originally was a deleted scene cut from
the first movie when the automatic doors
open it's completely foreign to them
pure magic they take it as a note that
how powerful that those girls are how
can we forget the Sanderson sisters
March the
they're going to town eating these
facial products when Mary calls the face
mask the face of a child it's so funny
to me and when he yells a newborn it
just really killed me I really like it
three people are dressed like the
Sanderson sisters and it could be off
the likeness to what people think they
saw in 93. we learned in Gilbert's
speech people allegedly saw them flying
that night they asked for a photo and on
the phone you see that like bubbly case
that you can pop because these kids are
young folks this movie came out almost
30 years ago so of course the kids are
going to be young they like them now
once the Sanderson sisters realize the
lotions are not potions they attempt to
fight Lizzy and Becca though they
cunningly know to use salt which combats
Winnie's lightning bolts which we saw in
the first movie when they're fighting at
the graveyard what a clever White Witch
we've got our new mode of transportation
for the Sanderson sisters that tiny
witch broom from a costume mannequin and
instead of a mop Sarah has a Swiffer Wet
jet and a pair of roombas for Mary which
is super funny to me because as we know
Mary had an old school vacuum in the
first movie and also this jogger just
jog right past these people flying on
brooms Sarah excited
which is her second favorite chant and a
call back to the first movie
when the Sanderson sisters get home
Sarah is immediately sat in to not find
her lucky rat tail but excited to see a
boy which both again are callbacks to
the first movie and A peculiar chain of
events Gilbert actually witnessed the
Sanderson sisters in 93. he said a bunch
of boys stole all my Candy probably ice
and Jay and he watched the witches die
at the cemetery the flashback gives us
Alice Danny and Billy Max lying on the
ground all just like in the first movie
they're going to do the power spell
which was worn to us at the very
beginning of the movie but when he
refuses to read the warning label that
comes attached which later on at the end
of the movie bites her in the butt they
need to find a formal Lover's head which
is butter juice of an Aurelia Berry one
petrified spider and one drop of thy
enemy's blood the recipe I guess is a
little loose because you can use like a
spider from a fair prize so do with it
which you will first starting with
trask's blood while Gilbert goes to
Billy's grave to retrieve his head and
guess who's alive Billy Billy's been
alive this entire time and he's played
by my favorite person on the planet Doug
Jones he's reprising the role Doug also
mentioned an interview that the wig he's
wearing is the same wig from the first
movie it had been sitting on the
producer David kirschner's office all
these years technically Billy laid
himself back to rest but he never went
back to sleep my favorite part is Billy
actually correcting the old story that
Winnie was in love with Billy and Billy
cheated on her with Sarah I guess he
kissed her once and she sullied his name
since his entire mission in this movie
is the change is known history and
that's why he's working with Gilbert
when the sisters first arrived to the
festival we see signs for such dance
like apple plectic a play of apoplectic
to be overcome with anger the Bon
Appetit and Grave e lifestyles of the
witch and famous could be a play off the
song or the TV show The Story already
had a ton of hanging in the jokes if the
frame was Salem witch's run amok into
2022 you can make a ton of beats off of
that the reaction to the lotion the
filters on the camera and now the
bobbing for apples as live torture the
jokes will start writing themselves soon
like the poison caramel apple and the
scene of them accidentally talking to
Siri cobweb potentially could be a
familiar and he'd be the best he's so
perfect also did we know that the book
could sweat that's so insane the
Sanderson scissors make their way to a
much bigger stage Outdoors peep the
person on the very front dressed as
Ursula they're called The Originals and
after losing the Sanderson sister's
cosplay competition they're about to get
down I'm fangirling also I can spot
Ginger mint cornbread and Kimora Hall a
mile away they're from RuPaul's Drag
Race and I love them each and what a
great cameo in the first movie we had a
revamped I Put a Spell on You this time
we've got blondies one way or another
but they've mixed it in with their
original spell from the first movie and
I love it this dance number is great I
had so much fun and excuse me when
Winnie is flying by she notices two boys
watching the first Hocus Pocus movie on
their TV it's the Satan scene with Gary
and Penny Marshall they break before the
wall and it's so wild also the devil
that was supposed to hold a spot in line
for the mayor is dressed as Gary and
Penny Marshall at the front of the dance
mob we see a Madonna costume like the
homage to the first film we have our
Billy butcherson also front and center I
love the contrast we get later of both
Trio covens also the clothes for our
young witches are all nods to the styles
of Allison and Max from the first movie
Cassie's cardigan and tie-dye's shirt
are called backs to Max and Allison
while Izzy's burgundy cardigan also pay
tribute to Allison's red jacket from the
first film it's also a call back to the
original movie when Mary thinks Becca's
name is shishka baby well if it isn't
and what's her name again
um
because in the first movie She referred
to Danny as shishka baby and she's so
well fed isn't she
baby Billy and Gilbert getting along is
one of the best Side Stories I could
have asked for Gilbert promised Billy
all these items would help kill Winnie
but when Billy finds out the truth he
loses Billy mainly even as a friend also
the two people that walk by could be
dressed as the ghost from The Haunted
Mansion and I think that's just really
fun either way Gilbert reaches the Yang
Billy's head off and he says not again
because he lost his head in the first
movie and he's just gonna keep losing
his head that's what happens to zombies
when the mayor pulls up to his house and
the Sanderson sisters then gets the sun
rising Mary says this my mistake it's
just a very small bus referring back to
the first movie where they got on the
bus with the Mr weirdo bus driver
re-watch the first movie and listen to
what the bus driver says because it's
kind of weird Becca's hands light up
blue when she's trying to save Cassie
and we see a little sneak peek of that
when she's lying the salt down in
Walgreens also when she's using the
Angelica leaves in the basement Billy
also just loves calling Winnie a hag
which we see done in the first movie a
couple times when they begin the ritual
the book is given the chance to choose
and he decides to stick with Becca
because unlike Winnie she gives him a
choice remember the book doesn't want to
even do this spell in the first place
this is also what leads me to believe
that the first witch that gave them the
book also lost her Coven in the exact
same way performing this damn spell we
learned that there's a warning with the
spell and if you want to be the most
powerful you'll lose what means most to
you which in this case is Winnie's
sisters and like the first movie Sarah
and Mary leave a glitter dust with the
last words they said in the first movie
This is actually a very sad scene I
didn't make it sound as sad as it is but
it's really sad and I hate it it made me
cry just a little bit this is kind of a
cautionary tale to the young coven which
could have been a cautionary tale from
the first witch as well when he is
willing to give up her powers because
her powers are nothing to her without
her sisters am I bald this new little
coven's first spell out of the book is
the spell to reunite unfortunately it
doesn't bring them back but sends Winnie
to them she happily Glitters away to be
with her sisters again and are they gone
for good can they ever come back Becca
guesses they can't and honestly this is
different from the daylight taking them
or standing in the graveyard because
they just poof and they use the spell
it's like the strongest spell in the
book and now all the Spells are undone
including Billy finally getting to go to
sleep his eternal rest and thank God
Belize Gilbert could do is offered
discounts going forward to everyone to
do the Sanderson sisters walk into the
mist and the regular Halloween is
concluded during the credits we get the
Sanderson sisters singing the song from
the beginning in a recording studio I
genuinely love this song and love this
movie it's so fun it was so many fun
callbacks to the first movie a great
conclusion as well great coven support I
love sister stories I love sisters I
love reunions and also don't miss the
post credit scene because Cowboy is
pointing to a box that says black flame
candle number two so is there another
there has to be another could there be
another movie oh it's endless it's
possibilities are endless and that is my
breakdown an Easter egg video for Hocus
Pocus number two I really like the movie
I cried during the movie It's nostalgic
for me and definitely a bundle of Goofs
a very warm family spooky Disney movie
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
Lulu Clemens while a new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
horror content check out the break room
where we've been talking about all kind
of horror and Halloweeny things in
October thanks for watching and remember
that's all just a bunch of Hocus Pocus
yeah
[Music]